hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast practical considerations for
fluorescence and imaging I'm Julie on
child of lab herbs and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by libraries and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
thermo fisher scientific is the world
leader in servicing service serving
science our mission is to enable our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer we help our customers
accelerate life sciences research solve
complex analytical challenges improve
patient diagnostics and increase
laboratory productivity through our
premier brands the remote scientific
applied biosystems in vitro jim fisher
scientific immunity lab services we
offer an unrushed combination of
innovative technologies purchasing
convenient and comprehensive support for
more information please visit www mov
sure calm we have a few important
announcements before we begin the
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentations window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge this white window by
clicking on the screen icon in the left
in the lower right-hand corner of the
slide window we have any technical
problems viewing on hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left I mean I'd like to
introduce today's speaker Chilean
Blackmer trillium Blackmer is a senior
staff scientist in the bio sciences
division of thermo fisher scientific
located in order for the past seven
years she has worked in product
development of her fluorescence-based
probes and has also been the lead writer
and developer of an educational resource
for fluorescence imaging basics the
molecular approach school of
fluorescence
she received her BS in chemistry and you
know from University of San Francisco
and a PhD in molecular pharmacology and
toxicology from Northwestern University
Medical School she served in
postdoctoral positions in neuroscience
lab specializing in electrophysiology
and fluorescence microscopy before
moving over to biotechnology startup in
2008 her name's sake is a woodland
flower not a chemical I will now turn it
over to Chilean black mare for a
presentation hello everyone and welcome
today I am going to go over a few things
you can do to improve your imaging
experiment and also tell you about some
different reagents that can help in
experimental design and also in choosing
what reagents you would might want to
use to ask for your scientific questions
so the three main things that I'd like
to cover today are go over some of the
basic reasons you might want to use
fluorescence in your microscopy
experiments bring up some common
problems that both experts and even
beginners run into and different ways
that you can solve those problems
science is mostly about iteration it's
about 1% inspiration ninety-nine percent
iteration so we'll go over some tips and
tricks and then reagents and instruments
that can also help with some of those
problems and then lastly if I don't talk
too much I'll mention a few online
resources that thermo Fisher has that
can give you some of the material you
see today and also some apps for your
phone that can help with experimental
design and protocols so a brief history
of molecular probes it was founded by a
chemist in Minnesota in his kitchen and
then they moved to Texas in the late 70s
and started a company
there and you'll see some of the place
names from where he moved around the
country in the names of the dies for
instance Texas red and then he relocated
to Oregon the a place near eugene which
is where we're located now and so you'll
sometimes see some of the names like
Oregon Green is a common died name that
molecular probes catalog contains but
but really the more famous dies and
probes that were known for were
developed in the 90s and those included
the my toe trackers lie so trackers flow
for am things like that and we'll go
over some of them today we've gone
through a few different corporation
parent corporation name changes in vitro
gen acquired molecular probes and then
merged with ABI and we were known as
life technologies but now we've been
acquired by a thermo Fisher and that's
our parent corporation those phone
numbers you see on your screen our phone
numbers the 800 number is directly to
molecular probes technical support and
the 541 number is if you wanted to talk
to a real person at our front desk so
why do we use fluorescence in microscopy
one of the big reasons we use it is for
resolution the modern CCD cameras that
acquire the images that we usually
acquire in fluorescence microscopy have
a much bigger range in there both the
wavelengths that and their sensitivity
and so what you see here is under the
blue peak is what the human eye can
generally see if you're young you can
see all the way out to 700 nanometers
usually older eyes like mine can't even
see that far and it cuts off somewhere
in the 600's but you can see that ccd
cameras can see a much a long wider
range of wavelengths and that helps and
they're also much more efficient into
how many photons they need to see detect
a signal so resolution is one of the
main reasons we would use fluorescence
microscopy another reason is selectivity
so what you can see in this side is in
this slide is a the same floor floor
which is that green blob labeled floor
for and it's conjugated to different
things and that's what provides
specificity for where it goes in the
cell so in the first example its
conjugated this floor for is conjugated
to a molecule that targets actin and you
can see an example of what it looks like
when you label actin and green in the
little picture below in the middle
example the fluorophores been conjugated
to an antibody and then you can see that
usually their secondary antibodies and
you can see in the picture below what's
happened when you've used immunolabeling
to deliver that fluorescent signal and
then the last example which is a little
less common today but it still gets used
is is where you deliver the floor for to
the internal area of the cell maybe by
injection and that's usually when the
floor is in a salt form and you can look
at trap you know look at cell processes
and how they grow so those are all the
same fluorophores and and they just are
change in their selectivity with how
they're conjugated or how they're
applied to the cell so that's another
really convenient feature for
fluorescence microscopy another big one
which you're seeing in the slide here is
the contrast that fluorescent labeling
provides so when you look at that
transmitted light image you can see that
you get some detail but not a lot and if
you label the nucleus and the actin
filaments with fluorescent labels you
get a lot more contrast between them and
their surroundings so you get a more a
better picture of the structures inside
and outside
the cell when you use fluorescent labels
so for example this is just another
picture that shows you what something
looks like these cells are proliferating
and this is in bright field and then if
you were to look at it with labels
delivered to the Golgi and the nucleus
you could see that you can see that the
nucleus is here in green the Golgi is in
red and you get a lot more information
than you did just with right field so
with any advantage there always are
costs associated with it and Sciences no
exception some common issues that people
run into when they use fluorescent
microscopy can include background
fluorescence we're going to spend quite
a bit of time talking about ways to
improve your signal to background and
which dies and reagents to choose
sometimes you might run into problems
where your cells seem to be dying once
you put them on the microscope or you
might have experimental questions about
how many cells are dead how many are
alive we'll we'll go over some reagents
that can help there and then there's
also issues of phototoxicity we're going
to going to explain what phototoxicity
is and some ways to avoid it same with
photo bleaching and other common
problems so signal to background is
really the name of the game when it
comes to a successful fluorescent
imaging experiment and and the way we
define signal and background is we say
signal is the fluorescent probe giving
you a signal from where you want it to
be so if you have a specific probe it's
the fluorescence you want to see
background is basically fluorescence
from everywhere else and it can be non
Mon on specific background fluorescence
and it can come from a variety of places
in your experiment and that's what this
little cartoon is showing you so it
can come from the media that your cells
are in when you do your imaging
experiment it can come from the vessel
it can come sometimes from the reagents
that you use or even your sample this is
especially problematic in tissue where
they have it has a lot of
autofluorescence so we'll go over
briefly go over a few different ways to
kind of work around the background
fluorescence in each of these areas so
that your signal is nice and bright and
you can do a successful experiment first
of all before you get started just make
sure your microscope is functioning
properly that might be really basic but
it's key and what you're seeing here you
might think oh that you're looking at
these blue blobs are nuclei that are
labeled with a fluorescent probe hurts
and you might think that over there in
the corner where it's very dim that just
a really low signal and somehow they
were labeled unevenly but that's not the
case what happened here was that the
microscope was not in alignment and so
this meant that the picture looked
dimmer in some areas and brighter and
others and it was due to just the light
was didn't have a clear path so make
sure your microscopes functioning
properly and if you have a question
about it if you're just beginning you
might ask somebody else look at
something that you think should have a
really good label make sure that all the
field of view has the same amount of
signal before you start to troubleshoot
your actual experimental design another
thing that people don't always like to
hear but it's actually pretty important
is that usually when you purchase a dye
to use on yourselves a range of
concentrations are given and that's
because the optimal concentration for
your particular cell or tissue may not
be the same as someone else's so what
you really need to do if you're having
problems with signal and background is
to optimize your dye concentration and
what you're seeing here in this series
of panels is that concentration can
really matter
the one that's labeled 1 X is the
optimal amount of signal to background
and you can see and then the next panel
which should be labeled for X I
apologize it somehow the concentrations
got changed on the bottom there but in
the the bottom panel there then that is
it looks like your signals brighter but
the background has also increased so in
fact it's not the best concentration to
be using and then if you go all the way
up to 12 X you can see that the
background is even visible to you are I
not just to the camera and that that
would not be a good concentration to use
either so optimizing your diet
concentration checking a series a range
of concentrations can be helpful if
you're running into either low signal or
really high background another thing to
do when you're in the experimental
design portion of your your your
experiment is make sure that your floor
floors are the best match to the filters
on your microscope and that can prevent
what we refer to as lead through and
what you're showing here what you're
seeing here in this black and white
picture is a label that was used and it
was intended to be to label something
that would show up in the truth seat
channel and what happened was because
the dye was had such a broad emission
spectrum it actually did what we call
bleed through to another channel the
fitzy channel and it's not pseudo
coloured but you're just having a look
at it from the from just the image that
the camera records and you can see that
those actin filaments are actually
showing up in a channel they weren't
intended to and that could also give you
background fluorescence when in an area
you didn't want so in the next slide
just a reminder that if you are using
immunolabeling where you use antibodies
generally an imaging you use a
primary antibody against your epitope
and then a secondary antibody that has
the floor floor conjugated on it and you
just want to avoid having more than one
primary antibody raised in the same host
species if you're doing multicolored
with many different antibodies in the
next slide and I'm showing you a few
different pictures of imaging vessels
and so if you want your best like cover
of the journal quality fluorescent image
you're going to want to use glass and
that can be challenging sometimes cells
don't always like to grow on glass and
when you're doing live cells you want
your cell as happy as well so so that
you know you have to be the best judge
of when when you want to use the glass I
mean a lot of times if you look at that
orange lidded flask many times you're
checking cells in the actual tissue
culture vessel that's it's they're
commonly grown in that plastic is fine
for growing cells it's great and it will
work for quick checks but if you want a
really high-quality image you're going
to have to culture yourselves on glass
and that's because if you look in the
little cartoon at high magnification and
high resolution the glass is the best
match for immersion tiles that a lot of
high magnification objectives use
because the the refractive index is
matched the oil to the glass to the
optics in your objective so you'll just
get the best image there if you use a
glass vessel and someone's I really like
to use are these little round ones that
you see so they're they're plastic which
makes it easier to handle but then they
have a glass bottom in them and you can
see that those milk ones are quite handy
another thing to use if you're trying to
do a lot of experiments at the same time
is a 96-well plate that you can see in
the middle there in that top panel and
just some things to remember there if
you're using 96-well plates you want to
use probably
black plastic because it tends to have
less autofluorescence than white and you
want to use glass bottom ones that will
give you a better image so I kind of
changing tact a little bit if you've
taken care of the instrument and the
culturing vessel another thing to think
about is what solution your cells are
being imaged in if you're doing a live
cell experiment and something to
consider is to not image them in their
culture and media because culturing
media tends to have a lot of fluorescent
compounds in it that will give you
background when you're trying to look at
your specific fluorescent signal so one
thing that you can use is something that
we sell called a live cell imaging
solution it's a product that I developed
and it's based on ringers solution
ringers is light is a very old recipe
that physiologists have used since the
1800s it's also what you get and if you
go to the hospital and you have an IV
it's it's very related to to that drips
that goes into your but it's very
physiological the nice thing about it is
is optically clear and it will keep
yourselves very healthy well there on
the microscope but the caveat there is
that it's really best for experiments
that get done in four hours or less if
you want something where you're
following an experiment you're following
sells out and you want to image them for
some reason it's important that you
image them in the same media that they
were cultured in then the suggestion
there is to use a demon media that was
developed to be as optically inert as
possible and that's that flow bright
media that you're seeing on the slide
there it what you can see from the data
there and it supports proliferation of
cells so they proliferate and grow no
Emily but the background fluorescence is
much lower than demon it's comparable to
PBS or another saline solution and so
your signal to noise is comparable to
PBS which you don't get when you image
in demon or other media's like that but
it can also support proliferation and
and normal cell function that goes on
over a process of four hours or longer
and then and so then in the the next
slide what what we're kind of addressing
now are all the different questions you
can ask about how healthy your cells are
and you may be asking these questions
because you are studying a process that
involves cell viability or proliferation
or a dosis or you might be asking these
questions because you want to make sure
that your experimental technique isn't
changing or biasing your results in
terms of our yourselves still healthy
while they're on a microscope and you're
studying them and so something to
understand is really when we talk about
fluorescent imaging what we mean by a
live cell and what we mean by a dead
cell so what makes a cell alive is is a
philosophical question really and it
could be debated and has been but when
it comes to fluorescent reagents the way
we define a live cell is a cell whose
membrane is intact and it has enzymes
that can support the the cleavage of a
dye that when it's in its native form
it's not fluorescent but then by by
enzymes that all cells contain it could
something gets cleaved off and it
becomes fluorescent so that we take as
our live readout and then for a dead
readout that would be the case from a
from a basic fluorescent imaging
perspective where a
in permeant nucleic acid so it normally
cannot cross a healthy cell membrane but
when cells die their membranes become
Permian so you would get a signal from
your nucleus if you were using a dead
cell indicator that showed that that
nucleic acid was able to bind DNA and
Flores and it couldn't do that if the
cell membrane was healthy and intact so
that that's kind of important to keep in
mind when you're thinking about
lifestyle indicators and dead cell
indicators lifestyle indicators are
things that usually rely on an enzyme
substrate in yourself and dead cell
indicators are usually things that are
in permeant nucleic acid dyes that are
able to get to the nucleic acid in the
cell's nucleus because the cell is sick
or dying and its membrane is no longer
intact so one thing that that people run
into problems with is a lot of live dead
imaging kits don't fit into filter sets
very well there because they're based on
flow cytometry who tend to have a
different filter set up but we do have
one that's ideal for 50 and Texas red
filters and you can see this beautiful
image of a green live cells that means
that enzyme is active in those cells and
so they're fluorescent green and they're
the dead cells where the membranes are
permanent to nucleic acid dyes are
showing up as those red nuclei and I
think that in the next movie that's
played you can actually see a movie of
how the the cells would look if you were
looking in the ocular and they started
out healthy and then died
you
you
you
so what you saw there was that the cells
started out green and health that was
their lifestyle indication and then what
we did it the microscope is we actually
poison them we pipetted in a bunch of
DMSO that basically blew up their
membranes and killed them and you saw
that loss of green fluorescence and then
the red indication that the cells were
officially dead and so that's kind of
the sort of thing that was a very
dramatic example but that's the sort of
thing that you could expect to see if
you use a live dead imaging kit with
those fitzy and Texas red filter
selections so in the next slide we're
going to explain a little bit about
indicators for a pitocin which is
another you know this particular way
that cells can die is through an avett
otic pathway and sell event caste-based
37 is a reagent that um it's it's dark
it has no fluorescence until an enzyme
is activated in the a pathetic pathway
cafes 37 that's the enzyme and when that
happens it Cleaves off a peptide off of
this die and then it causes the dye
which is a DNA die to be free and able
to bind to DNA and so when you cleave
off that peptide the DNA the DNA die
kindle and bind to DNA and what you see
in no treatment is dark but when the
cells have been induced with to become a
patata with stores foreign what you see
there is that you get that green
indicator that tells you those cells are
undergoing apoptosis and it's a readout
in particular of the café's 37 pathway
so if you wanted to multiplex it with
something like TMR em TMR em is a
mitochondrial health read out and you
can
see at zero hour the missiles are
labeled with red them sort of those red
spots you see and that means their
mitochondria are all intact and
functioning but when the cells are
treated with staurosporine to evoke a
pitocin you can see that by about three
hours the red signal is all gone because
the mitochondria are no longer healthy
so they've lost that that signal of
mitochondrial health and by seven hours
most of the cells are green showing that
they've undergone a pitocin and that's
that cell event signal so um thats
element and a few of our other reagents
are actually available in a dropper
bottle format that you can keep on your
lab bench and all the protocols are the
same you just drop in two drops per mil
and you can look for those under the
ready probes reagent if you search for
that if I met on our website and that
includes cell event and some of the
other nucleic acid dyes so another
common question when it comes to self
health is oxidative stress oxidative
stress is reactive oxygen species that
get generated through a variety of ways
and we have a few really nice probes to
ask questions about whether your cells
are undergoing oxidative stress or not
the one you're looking at here is cell
rocks beet red and what you can see on
the top panel are the nuclei in control
those are blue nuclei and then what you
see when the cells are treated with
something that evokes hypoxia and they
so when they're in hypoxia they undergo
that oxidative stress and they generate
a lot of reactive oxygen species so then
you see that that little pinkish red
signal show up and what you see in the
bottom panel is that it that signals
retained
if you want to fix yourselves afterwards
which makes it convenient to do a live
cell imaging experiment and then fix it
and retain the signal and you can also
get this is a far read sensor which is
nice when you're you know working in
tissue or other things that the green
channel is being used but they're also
available in green and orange
wavelengths as well and i think that the
next slide is a movie where you can see
cell rocks green so what you'll see is
that the cells will start out with no
color but as they undergo oxidative
stress they'll become green
so that happened pretty fast but
hopefully you got the idea is sometimes
nice to see them in instead of just
pictures to see the kind of time time
frame you're talking about in a live
image so another common question to ask
about yourselves or tissue is um what's
proliferating and edu is a pretty common
way you use a modified uracil that that
labels DNA well DNA is being made and
that would be while your cells are
proliferating and then it gets
incorporated into the DNA and you can
label that special those special sugars
that got incorporated into the DNA while
the cells were proliferating and the
nice thing about the product that we
call click it edu is that it's not
radioactive so you can look at
proliferation fluorescently and it's
really a nice simple protocol because
you can see here the that the what be
what click it edu takes the place of is
what's referred to as added brdu
protocol and that can take all day
whereas the clickit edu is nice because
you do there you feed the cells they
proliferate and then the actual hands-on
work is about an hour and you get a
really nice read out in fluorescent
microscopy or flow or high throughput
imaging of which cells are proliferating
and which are not but one of the issues
with click it was that a lot of people
like to use gfp and green fluorescent
protein to label structures in their
cell and with classic brdu and click it
edu what you see there in that upper
panel is that you lose your GF p signal
base is due to the chemical component
of the reactions where you label that
DNA it kills the GFP signal so a lot of
customers talk to us and said you know
we really would like to be able to look
at proliferation using this non
radioactive quick way but we want to be
able to see our gfp signal as well so a
colleague of mine developed click it
plus edu and that's where the the
reaction has been reformulated it
preserves the GFP signal and the edu
signal and that's what you're seeing in
that third and all you're seeing the
nuclei in blue it's a little hard to see
but I think I think you can see them and
then you're seeing the GFP labeled cells
in green and you're seeing the cells
that were proliferating at the time they
were fixed in red so you can see you get
all of the signals you want and whereas
in the other two panels the brdu and the
classic click it you lost your GP signal
that that last panel is just a control
showing you that on the clickit signal
is in fact real and if you take away the
copper that's necessary to catalyze that
reaction then you lose your edu signal
so a nice thing about clicket is that is
a very specific readout of cell
proliferation and it works across almost
every species that's been tested and
you're seeing just a nice example of a
bunch of different species here from
zebrafish to Mouse and so it chicks
ecoli it basically has worked in almost
every species and kingdom that that's
been tested in so on this slide is here
to remind me that to talk about once
your cells are out of the incubator and
you're putting them on the stage of the
microscope to do your live cell imaging
vermin um it can be a very harsh
environment for cells they're used to
being in the incubator they're they're
used to their media being a certain pH
they're used to a certain amount of co2
and oxygen and so when you take them out
of that incubator and put them on the
microscope you have to be sure to do
some things to accommodate them and
control their environment and because if
you don't it's kind of like asking you
to get on that frozen bicycle and start
writing like you were writing on a nice
summer day and we can imagine how that
would go so one of the problems the
slide always kind of makes me a little
sad as an electrophysiologist who did
two photon imaging but it's true there
are usually a lot of steps involved in
doing high-resolution live cell imaging
a lot and you know I think this is 11 or
12 steps and people can get pretty
intimidated using it and trying to keep
yourself healthy and do all of the the
things you need to do to use this
instrument so there are instruments that
to be honest I was a little skeptical of
when I first started using them but now
I love them and I'm a big fan these are
digital microscopes that are really easy
to use there's not 11 steps or 12 steps
to turn it on you can you can do phase
you can do fluorescence microscopy and
it's nice because they're LED powered so
you have less photo bleaching in your
experiments which is good and my one of
my favorite things about them my
favorite one is the FL auto and the
reason I love it is because I'm a
physiologist and I love that you can get
an on-stage incubator that's pretty nice
and simple to use and that gets us back
to that's why we're going here you get
you can put yourselves in that nice
controlled environment so you can
regulate the temperature
the humidity how much oxygen they're
getting and it's all right there on the
stage of the microscope and it you can
control it digitally while you're you
know setting up your experiment and it's
a really nice feature I even like it
better now than my 12-step confocal but
I'm something else that's worth
mentioning just about the FL auto is
that you can get more than one kind of
camera so you can get color and
monochrome cameras and that that can be
really important when you're imaging
tissue and then it also does what we
call image stitching where it takes a
series of images of something really big
and can stitch them together to give you
a complete image of something at you
know magnification that normally you
couldn't collect all the images of and
that's really taking advantage of the
fact that it's a digital microscope but
now back to the hard stuff so one of the
challenges of live cell imaging is
phototoxicity and that is something that
that you'll see if you do live cell
imaging and you kind of have to learn
about it the hard way what you can see
here this is in a couple of different
examples what you can see on the top
panel that gray and green image is that
um if you look to the right where it
says illuminated area you can see that
the green signal is pretty dim and I
don't know if you can see it at a
resolution on your computer but you'll
have to take my word for it the cells
are really unhealthy looking the
membranes look terrible probably if you
had a dead cell indicator in there it
would be screaming red because those
cells have all died and what you see in
the non illuminated area is that you
have a nice bright green fluorescent
signal from your GF p labeled nuclei and
the cells are happy and thriving and and
sometimes people think that that's from
you know the expression of a probe or or
labeling with a
I it's really not it's it's from the
actual light that you shine on your
cells to get the very images you want
can be toxic to cells and that's because
most cells are not intended to ever see
light the way we do when we interrogate
them on a microscope so they it's
something to be aware of and if you look
in the bottom panel um you're looking at
some fibroblast cells that had some
scratch wounds scratched across them and
then what and they're labeled with cell
tracker deep red and then and then it's
just showing you and you're going to
have to ignore the the the titles on the
bottom there because they got flipped
and I'm sorry but wait what you're
looking at in that scratch where there's
basically a tunnel through the cells the
cells are shown in red and they didn't
ever grow back into that scratch wound
and that's because they were under
illumination so they had gone undergone
time-lapse imaging for kenner 10 hours
and it wasn't the probe itself that that
caused that phototoxicity because if you
look in the non illuminated area the
cells have grown back into the wound and
you can see that that they're there
proliferating and they're healthy so
that that's phototoxicity and what that
is is it's so do deaths that's induced
by light exposure it tends to be
independent of fluorescent labels they
can contribute to some of the toxicities
associated with light but you can you
can cause your cells harm just by
shining light on them with no
fluorescent label at all and and the
what the things you should watch out for
when you're doing your lifestyle imaging
experiment our seen cells round up art
and detach its load off of the the
culturing vessel and if if you're used
to watching them move and grow and that
movement and growth slows and where you
tend to see these problems is when
you're doing live cells
when you're doing timelapses that are
that are over long periods of time so
what can you do to to get around that
well first of all you can make sure that
your cell environment is as comfortable
for the cell as possible and that goes
back to making sure that it's in you
know a solution that's physiological
it's the right pH is warm you know you
have that on stage incubator to keep
yourselves happy but then when it comes
to actually doing the imaging you
there's also a few things to keep in
mind if you see phototoxicity you could
use shorter exposure times and so you
know a lot of times we want to expose
for as long as possible to get the
highest quality image but when it comes
to time law time-lapse microscopy you
might need to cut back on your exposure
time so that the amount of light that
those cells see over time is lessened
you also as much as autofocus is nice to
use to find your focal plane you
probably don't want to do your
time-lapse where you've used the
autofocus you want to minimize that as
much as possible for those overnight or
long time lapse experiments because
autofocusing uses a lot of light so the
cells only can you know have so much
light shine on them and if you use that
up with your auto focus by the time you
do your actual experiment the cells will
be pretty unhealthy another thing to do
is to use optimal filters and we talked
about that a little bit you want to make
sure that that you're using the right
filter set so that you're harvesting as
much of the signal as possible it'll
mean you can use shorter exposure times
you also might think about if you're
trying to image over night or a whole
day you would might think nuc
phototoxicity you might want to think
about increasing the interval between
the times you take images so not only
shortening the amount of time that you
expose the cells to light and get your
image but also lengthening the amount of
time in between
images in your time lapse and the last
thing you can do is around die selection
so basically the brighter the die the
shorter the exposure time and the dye
matched to its filter will also allow
you to have much shorter exposure times
so what are some common really bright
dyes that are good to use when we're
trying to do cell biology life so on
live cell imaging organelle trapper dyes
are nice because they are very bright
and specific you can see them here
labeling the Golgi in red and the in
each case the nucleus is labeled in blue
lysosomes can be labeled using these
tracker dies mitochondria we saw some of
the we saw TMR em with the mitochondrial
self health indicator and then the ER
can be labeled as well so those are nice
bright reagents to try if you're another
thing to think about when you're
designing your experiment is that is is
that if you've got autofluorescence or
you're having problems with
phototoxicity you can try imaging out in
longer wavelengths those have less
energy associated with them and
sometimes they can help with your photo
toxicity issues so here just for example
is lie so tracker and it's in a deep red
so that would be a you know a long
longer wavelength red indicator another
way to label a cell's organelles and
structures is to use genetically encoded
labels and that takes advantage of
fluorescent proteins and you can send
the fluorescent proteins to different
structures in the cell the hard part
about that is how do you get that DNA
into the cell to be start with in order
to get your structures labeled on
the fluorescent proteins and a really
nice way to do it is to use the backhoe
virus on system and it's not it's not
actually a viral infection because it's
an insect virus so it's non toxic to
cells it's is labeled biosafety level 1
so if you're doing cell culture you can
do this and it's not replicating in
mammalian cells but what it does is it
delivers the DNA into the cell but then
the DNA has a mammalian promoter so the
virus the baculovirus is not able to
replicate and the expression of the
fluorescent protein targeted to these
various structures is driven by FML and
promoter and it's really nice because
you can have a really nice rate of
expression and in traditionally hard to
transfect cells like primary cells stem
cells neurons and you basically pipette
it into yourself so your plate of cells
and you wait you incubated overnight and
then by the next day you should have
labeled structures and sometimes it does
take a little titration right that goes
back to optimizing your label for your
specific subtype and so what we're
showing here though is that you get a
really nice high rate of transduction
with different a targeted gfp tubulin
mitochondrial in early early endosome
and then on the right there we're
showing just different um traditionally
difficult to transfect cell lines that
show nice bright signals you can see
hippocampal nodes so we talked about the
reagents a little bit and reagent
selection we we talked about different
questions you can ask of your cells and
we talked about media too immature cells
in
and vessels that could help cut down on
your background fluorescence sometimes
you do all of that and you still have a
signal that's being very challenging and
it's really hard to see above all in the
background there are products like this
one on its backdrop it's a background
suppressor and it works as a chemical
filter to suppress the fluorescence
outside of cell so so this reagent is
just intended for life cells is only
intended for internal targets and you
have to kind of be brave when you use it
because when you drop it into your your
media it will change the color of your
media it's basically a chemical filter
on your media but you have to keep going
and add enough because if you stop
halfway it actually just makes the
background horse but if you add enough
in the channel you want to suppress your
background you will be pleasantly
surprised and you can kind of see that
in the bottom panel there with the plus
sign and that's where in the cows that
calcium is a green fluorescent sell it
says that the the cell is alive as one
of those indicators we talked about
earlier and you can see that the
background has decreased and so now it's
darker and in the might of tracker red
when they use the red channel background
suppressor they've made it so you can
actually see those those healthy
mitochondria being labeled and then in
the blue channel again you can see that
it cuts way down on the background
hopefully you can still see that the
nuclei are labeled in on your computer
screen so that's something that you
would use for live cell and live cell
imaging for two to reduce your
background if you're having problems
with background and you're doing fixed
cell imaging then a possible thing to do
if you've exhausted everything else is
to look into using signal enhancer
that's one of those ready probes
reagents I talked about earlier and
that's in a dropper bottle and you put
it
on your fixed and / themselves before
the blocking or you could you actually
use it after the blocking as well but
generally we recommend you put it on
before you do your block pain step and
you would see you'll see some help there
where it'll reduce the background by
quite a bit and it might be then you
might be able to actually see those
dimmer signals so then while we're
talking about fixed cells another common
problem that I mentioned earlier is that
when you are doing your imaging
experiment you may have noticed that you
can sometimes see what we refer to as
photo bleaching and it's kind of related
to phototoxicity but instead of the
light am causing problems first the
cells I'm causing them to die the light
actually causes the floor floor to dim
and and that's from you know the the the
molecule can only for us so many times
and and so then when the light is shone
on it for too long or too many times it
starts to dim and what you can do to get
around that in your fixed and / emselves
is to use a multimedia that has anti
fades in it which prevent fading or
photo bleaching and a one that's pretty
nice to use is prolonged diamond and the
nice thing about it is it is that it
also preserves the GFP signal in cells
and you can see that in that middle
panel there that on the GFP signal
doesn't go away through repeated scans
and it stays nice and right because it's
protected along with other floor for us
as well so that can be something to look
at using if you're running into problems
with photo bleaching in your fix and
firm sells if you have issues excuse me
if you have issues during live cell
imaging it's a little trickier
a lot of those anti fades that prevent
photo blue jean also can be very toxic
to cells but there are there is
something that we offer are called
prolong life as opposed to prolong
dymond which I just mentioned and it's
to help with photo bleaching in a live
cell experiment and what you can see
here is that this HeLa cells are
expressing mitochondria that's been
labeled with gfp and you can see that
the pro long live in the media will help
prevent that gfp from photo bleaching
compared to clip complete media shown
underneath and it basically increases
the amount of time that you can image
your gfp-expressing cells live cells by
about fifty percent so um i hope that
this seminar has been helpful if if you
want similar information and information
about reagent and protocols we do offer
some free apps for your for your mobile
devices and i'm showing you the URL at
the bottom there or you can just search
cell imaging in the application stores
and then another resource that's there
for you is at ww are mel fisher calm
backslash imaging basics and that's that
has a lot of information some of it I've
covered here about different things if
you're new to fluorescent imaging that
that you might want to know about and so
that's that's there to use and with that
I'll go over the key takeaways and so
keys to successful imaging experiments
the practical considerations that the
title alluded to reduce your background
do everything you can to make your
signal high and your background low and
and if you make that
you know the signal that you which is
what you want to see in the background
which you don't want to see
fluorescently labeled as as big as
possible you'll have the best outcome
for your experiment you also if you're
doing live cell imaging you need to keep
yourselves really happy with
environmental controls because you can't
just pop them on that icy bicycle and
expect them to pedal away and then
lastly you want to pick bright
fluorophores that give you a nice bright
signal so that you can use as little
light as possible for excitation and
then you want to excite at the most
optimal wavelength for the floor for
your using which means match your
filters to your floor for make sure your
instruments functioning properly and
with that all close and I believe that
you can ask questions in the in the QA
and thank you for attending thank you
for that informative presentation before
we get started on the question and
answer session I would like to remind
our audience how to submit questions you
get to make questions by typing them
into the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to answer as many questions as
we can our first question which of these
regions would work in tissues that's
always a very common question and just
like most of biology the answer is it
depends which is never what people want
to hear but um it really depends on what
reagent you are looking to use some of
them can work well in tissue and it's
really going to be tissue dependent the
one that always works in almost every
tissue that people have tested it in was
click it edu and click it plus and those
are
are the things that label proliferation
and those work very well in tissue other
other dies that we mentioned here like
the trackers and things like that it'll
be really dependent on the tissue itself
the next question the cell event come in
any other color besides green I think
the question was um de sel event come in
any color besides green and the answer
is unfortunately no not right now cell
event is the the probe that was four
castes activity in the AP tonic pathway
and we really we know that our customers
really want it in other colors and the
chemists and biologists here at
molecular probes are working as hard as
they can and as soon as we have
something that we think does a good job
we will be selling it but right now the
the one that works the best is just
available in the green color I would
like to once again thank Julian black
mare for her presentation do you have
any final comments no I don't have any
final comments just be sure to check out
those web resources and you can always
call customer support that phone number
was given in the beginning of the slide
if you have questions about molecular
approach products
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing until June 2017 you
will receive an email from rabbits
alerting you when this webcast will be
available to replay we invite you to
forward that announcements to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time and goodbye